[Music]
my name is joe diy i restore old toy
trucks and today i'm going to be walking
you through the restoration of a 1960
structo airport lift truck
these toys are considered press steel
toys that means they take a sheet metal
aluminum and they use a hydraulic press
to kind of form it into shape the
truck's pretty rusty it's mostly
complete which is good because they're
hard to find parts for the only thing
it's really missing was a lot of the
lights and mirrors that you'll see on
the roof
whenever i take things apart i always
start at the wheels and then i'll move
on and start taking the body off the
chassis and kind of work my way down to
the chassis usually that's the last part
that will be together
the reason i do this is it's just easier
to work from like the outside in
everything is attached to that chassis
so you need to get off you know piece by
piece and just work your way down there
here i'm using a rotary tool to grind
off the end of the rivet uh whenever
it's put in that kind of mushroomed at
the end so that they won't fall out so
you need to take off that that ridge
that you can pull the rivet out and
allow the pieces to come off when i take
them apart i use a lot of different
tools uh a screwdriver and pliers are
the main tools i use usually you can use
the screwdriver to to bend out the tab a
little bit and then once you get it away
from the toy then you can use your
pliers to fully bend it out and those
tabs are what's going to hold a lot of
the parts together so it allows you to
to get those tabs out and slide the
truck apart
once the trucks completely disassembled
i take it over to my sandblasting booth
and i try to remove all the paint and
rust
likely the rust came from just over time
this toy being played with probably left
outside it would get beat up and get
paint chips at any anytime you have
exposed steel to air into to moisture in
the air and oxygen that's when you get
rust forming
i'm removing the rust with a sandblaster
it's a sandblast cabinet in the media
inside of it spraying out aluminum oxide
so you can think of it like a really
abrasive powder
that gets shot through the gun
so you get a lot of air behind it it's
just blowing it at that toy as hard as
it can and that abrasive material will
take off any rust paint or anything
that's left on the metal
you have to remove all the rust before
you repaint it or powder coat it any
rust or oxide that's left underneath
that layer will eventually continue to
rust and come through your paint or come
through your powder coat or it may not
even stick properly in the first place
but we're down to bare metal now we can
go ahead and powder coat our parts
for powder coating i use an eastwood
powder coater pretty much what this
machine does is it takes
powdered plastic and it mixes with air
and sprays the powder at the parts and
then there's an electrical charge inside
the powder coating gun which is going to
discharge with the powder in the air and
pretty much electrically charge that
cloud of powder that electrified air
wants to find the closest ground and
that's what causes it to stick to the
part so as you watch it get powder
coated you'll see that the cloud of dust
just clings to the metal
after it's coated i put it in my little
electric oven it gets up to about 400
degrees fahrenheit and what that's gonna
do is melt down that powder and that's
where you see it change color to go from
a dull color to a glossy color that's
called the flow once it flows out then
you allow it to cure and that's what's
going to harden the color on there
all said and done powder coating is very
quick from putting it in the oven till
the time you can take it out and handle
it it's about 15-20 minutes
so now i'm going to go ahead and just
clean the tires i'm only washing the
black rubber part of the tire because
i'm just going to clean these up and use
them as is
i just put this in a solution of simple
green inside my ultrasonic cleaner and
i'm running it at about 40 degrees
celsius for about 20 minutes just
vibrating the parts
all that's gonna do is just remove any
of the dirt and crud that's caught in
the crevices and the uh the tread on the
tires
so now the white wall side of the tire
is all stained so i need to get this
back to the white color i put this in a
mix of hydrogen peroxide
in bleach and then you want to expose it
to uv light so i usually just put it
outside in the sun for a few days and
that bleaches it back to the original
white color
[Music]
this truck is a little rare because of
the moving body on the back that makes
it a little uncommon
a lot of people out there seek these
kind of operational vehicles the ones
that have a lot of moving parts on them
so the most difficult part of the
restoration is definitely putting this
thing back together there are a lot of
rivets located underneath the body that
need to all be in place so that the body
will move up and down properly and you
know everything will function as it
should
once i have everything cleaned up and
painted i'll usually start by assembling
the cab i usually do this because it's
got the windshield and it's just a it's
a nice easy part that i can just start
to to assemble before i start moving on
to the chassis
so when i'm putting it back together i
try to use the original style rivets and
then i use a special tool that'll crimp
them in the same style that that's what
i had from the factory
the two main tools i use for
reassembling is a clamp tool called the
pintonka tool and that just crushes the
original style rivets it's specially
designed just for tonkas and pinball
machines
the other tool is a small brass hammer
one side of the head's brass the other
side's nylon and that allows me to bend
the tabs without marring any of the
paintwork
[Music]
[Music]
the logos are reproduction stickers i
find online there's a bunch of
reproduction companies out there that
make them and i just get them from there
and reapply them
and after all that it's fully assembled
and ready to be played with again